oh banner wants to take it inside and he  does take it inside  the half court is given the golden  eagles a little trouble but somebody's  gonna get an open look  [Music]  [Applause]  florida chasing it down lewis for the  tie  that's not fair  [Music]  the upset makers are history makers  and oral roberts is in the sweet 16.  lisa they have done it again the golden  eagles have knocked off the gators  shooting the three ball 10 for 30.  but they got to that free throw line 19  for 23.  one of the best in the country is  shooting free throws and  rebounding down the stretch was the  difference paul mills told this team  after the ohio state win our staff has  been involved look at the tulsa reaction  enjoy it soak it in